vive la quarantaine maintenant en france
et à l'étranger
on avait dès le début en fait les
mesures de quarantaine ou de précaution
donc les 14 premiers jours ici à
shanghai était vraiment ce qu'on peut
appeler vraiment quarantaine où on était
les seuls déplacements dehors c'était
pour aller chercher la nourriture
strauss kahn marché tous les parcs ont
été fermées les restaurants les bars les
les magasins obligation de porter un
masque à une obligation de se laver les
mains et de se faire prendre la
température
partout à l'entraidé des immeubles à
l'entraidé des quelques magasins ouverts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois qu'il soit aussi
facile d'avoir des vélos aussi en chine
en libre service
beaucoup de gens nous quand vous voyez
la vie a repris les gens commencent à
ressortir il ya deux semaines je pense
j'aurais été le seul
donc là ce que vous voyez tous les
gardes à 6
c'est les entrées de ce qu'on appelle
les lignes les lane c'est les petits
quartiers résidentiels à l'intérieur de
la ville
donc là il faut
la température chaque entrée de
de lijn ou de quartiers en fête ou
d'immeubles à des gardiens comme ça des
comités de quartier et ils enregistrent
les gens qui rentrent fresnes à
température de tout le monde tout le
temps il donne des droits d'entrée ou de
sortie
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est un supermarché qui à côté de chez
moi
là c'est un peu vide normalement il ya
du monde maintenant qui revenu c'était
un des rares endroits de devis encore
pendants l'attend dans la vraie
quarantaine maintenant tu es un peu
dernier voit l'entrée ou la sortie
vérifie la température dans la vie
quotidienne
on retravaille et bien fondamentalement
on s'est créé leur propre routine
pas d'inquiétude on a repris 1
beaucoup de livres qu'on n'avait pas lu
on a beaucoup joué
l'infâme mario kart ou un chemin je me
suis fait je me suis pris un des raclées
phénoménal par ma copine
heureusement aux échecs je la battais
niveau 1 suis pas le meilleur
ma copine niveau devant la quarantaine
c'est difficile parce que c'est
l'impression la l'impression de savoir
qu'on ne peut pas sortir qu'on peut
faire qu'on est con et limités dans nos
déplacements et dans ce qu on peut faire
tous les jours ah bon j'ai la chance de
pas avoir un job qui sont difficiles
parce que ça met en péril le boulot
comme dans la restauration
je pense à l'hôtel rixos très dur mais
sinon la quarantaine ça pour ceux qui
sont inquiets
vaut mieux la prendre calmement de se
trouver des choses à faire on est en
chine et en chine il ligne
25 millions à shanghai tout était fermé
et il n'y a jamais eu de pénurie
personnes s'est ruée dans les magasins
pour acheter plus que ce qu'ils avaient
le système des livraisons les livraisons
à domicile sont mises en place
rapidement et on a on a on a pas mal
vécu à la quarantaine en fait c'était
c'était un passage obligatoire